hi i'm jeff elenor game director at
warner brothers games montreal and today
i'm really excited to share with you
gameplay footage featuring nightwing and
red hood from our upcoming game gotham
knights
hurry it up will ya
[Music]
[Music]
we're joining nightwing also known as
dick grayson midway through the game
story as he patrols our city
all of the knights can unlock heroic
ways of getting around the city for
nightwing it's his glider the flying
trapeze
the regulators gang are engaged in a
hacking crime so it's time to bring some
vigilante justice to the bad people
each crime in gotham knights plays like
a mini game mode with rules and optional
objectives
nightwing's fighting style is acrobatic
and ping pong's around the battlefield
[Music]
while you can play the whole game solo
you can also protect gotham and co-op
with a friend
his red hood red hood gained new
abilities after being resurrected by an
assassin cult here he uses mystical leap
to move across the rooftop springboarded
by his own soul energy
successful attacks and dodges build up
my momentum bar below and timing my
strikes and combos correctly makes it
build faster
once the bar is full heroes can unleash
powerful abilities
alright
red hood's range attacks are a little
louder he fires non-lethal rounds that
still do a lot of damage
[Music]
here's red hood's barrage ability which
deals piercing damage to interrupt
armored attacks
[Music]
the ui you're seeing can be customized
to your preferences what's on screen is
what i like but you can set it the way
you like
[Music]
now together
[Music]
only perfect attack nightwing
[Music]
now that we've prevented the regulators
from stealing data let's follow red hood
for a bit
the bat cycle is usable by all heroes in
gotham nights
let's watch red hood chase down a
smuggling van in southside neighborhood
great
our [ __ ] heads to beat up
[Music]
[Music]
red hood can unlock the ability to
attach a bomb to thrown opponents so he
can detonate it with a shot later
it's a pretty good time
oh
[Music]
now we're back at the belfry the hero's
home base this next sequence is from
early in the game as we're just
discovering the court of owls
[Music]
the bat computer runs the map of the
city and lets us pursue challenges and
advance the story
[Music]
nightwing is tracking his next story
mission investigating the old powers
club
the workbench is where we go to upgrade
our equipment making sure that we're
ready for each new challenge through the
game
players find blueprints and crafting
materials by taking on missions and
fighting crime
each blueprint has different stats
giving the player a wide range of cool
choices for their individual strategy
and style
gear with mod slots is better because
mod chips power up gameplay properties
[Music]
[Music]
at this point in the story our
characters are still processing the loss
of batman
[Music]
you could visit him
i could what
he went to yours when
you could visit his grave
you haven't
i'm not the one staring at that
you know
[Music]
sometimes you're an idiot grayson
[Music]
players can unlock fast travel to get
around the city in a hurry with the fast
bat
belfry got anything court related
the court of owls a secret society as
old as gotham itself we're on the city
behind closed doors according to the old
poem anyway
okay but how does that line up with what
penguin said
if this all-powerful court really is out
there they might be the ones getting all
those creeps out of blackgate
which means they've been getting away
with murder for centuries
i hear you
fingers crossed we'll learn more at the
powers club
it's time for nightwing to sneak into
court territory
stealth is always an advantage
i'm in
be careful let us know if you find
anything
they have a few guards for a long lunch
too huh
i'm not complaining nice to get a break
once in a while
so what do you think the poor bastard
did
what poor bastard as far as i know i
just got a longer break
poor bastard
i wonder what that means
[Music]
every hero has unique takedowns and
finishing moves
ambush strikes are faster than silent
takedowns but make more noise in peace
augmented reality vision helps the
heroes solve puzzles and investigate
mysteries ar shows a trail of blood
i wonder what else it can see
there's something under the floor
the hatch is connected to some kind of
network
there's got to be a way to open it
here we see nightwing's elemental
shockwave ability it interrupts enemy
armored attacks and deals elemental
status effects try this
cryo status freezes an enemy taking them
out of the fight for a while
[Music]
and
done
[Music]
a hidden staircase
that can't be good
[Music]
[ __ ] what's he doing here
i got something for you
[Music]
for anybody wondering how this fight
looks with red hood check this
about the out
red hood takes on a talon gladiator here
one of the court of owl's engineered
superhuman assassins
oh yeah here we go
this fight is not open
[Music]
wherever this belongs to must be in bad
shape better hurry
[Music]
that must be whoever they kidnapped
[Music]
[Music]
again
pre-order now and get the 233 custom bat
cycle skin